[Music]
the deadline
the pressure the anxiety
the stress is too much to bear how will
you get through the night
coffee's not working and you're
desperate what's this
it's kind of doing the trick feeling a
bit
weird and it's like you have wings
what is red bull can too much of it hurt
you
and what happens to your body when you
drink it
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you drank 1 000 red bulls in a month
in parts of the united states grassroots
movements are
pressuring officials to restrict the
sale
of energy drinks to minors due to severe
health concerns from
binge drinking red bull is one of
various brands being targeted so what is
red bull
it was first developed in thailand as a
drink to improve stamina
and it's been around since the late
1970s
although it didn't become popular until
an austrian marketer discovered it
in 1984. three years later the
red bull gives you wings slogan made its
debut
and since then 82 billion
cans have been chugged back with seven
and a half billion of those
in 2019 alone one can
of regular red bull contains caffeine
sucrose
glucose citric acid taurine vitamin b12
carbonated water sodium bicarbonate
calcium
pentathonate and artificial and natural
colors including flavors
sounds perfectly healthy right that
might depend on what your definition
of healthy is but can too much red bull
hurt you
well one 250 milliliter red bull
contains 80 milligrams of caffeine and
a whopping 27 grams of sugar
if you drink one of these the effects
might not be too bad but pounding back
one after another will definitely leave
you in a jittery mess
and curiously over 34
deaths have been linked to the intake of
energy drinks
other than caffeine and sugar the
excessive amounts of b
vitamins and high taurine levels will
cause you problems
b vitamins are good for you and can ease
stress but
too much of them can be dangerous high
levels of b3 and b6
can cause gastrointestinal problems
liver toxicity
blurry vision and nerve damage likewise
taurine is an amino acid that helps in
neurological development
and regulates water and minerals in the
blood
but you shouldn't overdo that either in
animal studies increased ingestion of
taurine
has been shown to decrease body weight
and cause dehydration
so what would happen if you drank 1 000
red bulls in a month the math is
daunting
drinking 1 000 red bulls in 31 days
means gulping 32 cans of the stuff each
day
that's two cans per hour if you stop for
eight hours of sleep
since there's no time to lose let's get
started
10 minutes in the caffeine from the
first red bull permeates the bloodstream
your heart rate and blood pressure now
start to rise
after 15 to 45 minutes you may have
better concentration
or just feel more wired depending on how
fast you downed the entire can
the caffeine is completely absorbed 30
to 50 minutes later
pupils will dilate blood pressure rises
even higher
and the body releases bursts of insulin
with caffeine blocking the effects of
adenosine
a necessary chemical involved in the
sleep process
the body kicks into full-on emergency
adrenaline response mode the liver dumps
extra sugar into the bloodstream and
it's converted into fat after one hour
you may start to feel a major sugar
crash and
the effects of the caffeine start to die
down
congratulations you just survived the
first
hour and there's only 30 more cans to go
today
not to worry you probably won't survive
the entire 31 days anyway because
you'll likely experience a caffeine
overdose in the first two weeks
consider this you'll be consuming 160
milligrams of caffeine
every hour you are awake that's 2560
milligrams in 16 hours
the negative effects of caffeine would
have already kicked in around the
300 to 500 milligram mark to overdose on
caffeine
you would need to reach a 10 gram level
of intake
since one 250 milliliter can
contains 80 milligrams of caffeine it
would only take
125 cans of red bull to
totally overdo it you could also forget
about that eight hours of sleep we
estimated
with all that sugar and caffeine in your
system it's no surprise that insomnia
is often a reported side effect then
there's the physical aftermath of trying
such a challenge
high blood pressure increase for risk of
type 2 diabetes
heart disease kidney problems not to
mention your
teeth would look disgusting from the
enamel being stripped off
it's safe to say no one should ever try
to drink this many red bulls
our bodies aren't made to function well
in this constant
hyped up state of fight or flight even
drinking
one can of red bull probably isn't doing
your body any favors
but we wouldn't expect you to give up
caffeine entirely
can you imagine what our world would
look like if everyone
stopped drinking coffee well that's a
story
for another what if
[Music]